well welcome to the last session because
time is short my name is Robert I go on
in the size department are the first
person on our session for the session
now on regional issues and crane the
mission rock group and regional issues
how to she who is number of the
Ukrainian product from the Ukrainian
People's Party and as I understand it
member the Commission you created East
European issues it also says analista
member of the Foreign Affairs Commission
that's not correct okay years ago a
teacher and western Ukraine at the State
University so we're delighted to having
you today he's been working on these
issues issues
for shores efficiently as a leader for a
party mr. kasky is very busy this column
enter election going to houston au is
detained by Belarusian authorities yeah
we were prepared for that he was here a
bit and villa Russia elections well
that's why I will speak instead of him
and I'm real sorry I will speak ukraine
and we to be better understandable as I
asked my good friends the color is
granted help us this frustration yet
what further the Stasi you go Lucy a
little worried Democratic velocimetry
why the solution is death patrol
Lukashenko atresia pissing Torian rasiya
maybe she should be Lucy mortgages
Democritus wat Sebastian there are two
ways that people say that you can
democratize bureaus one way is to the
way to Lukashenko leaves but to be more
exact weight so Russia allows builders
to be democratized really good hit with
a unique Domo Domo not very motivational
rusev rusev training was not just in the
stupid pillow Lucy a cure same process
will receive it Novartis region and the
second approach these processes are
became popular last year was that on the
wave of Democratic revolutions in
Georgia decrying the same name could be
a similar revolution could happen in
Villa Rosa this would be much paper
approach why I chose like many technical
as you pollution gurus yeah words of us
would lost boom Winston at his facility
and basing basing on the fact that i had
the opportunity travelin be loose saddle
cons this past year i would like to say
that the truth is somewhere in the
middle you sure going to choose red it
was a guru see to some park Baroness
Anya favorite shows emotion
perrin a sneak attack is a tasting
delicate new balance give a very rainy
nadu boogaloo siempre y cuando pokazat a
pc version sure process Democratic rules
in a post Rajesh compras three-second
Jersey which Anna's process Muslims
what's the business yellow controversy
Sebastian moment aqui because I into it
single-family so grainy photo sure valio
Trojan War morandini is no better watch
his vision is deliberate dollars there
there's a painting that the fact that
the yellow Russian actions were moved to
one day to within one week of the
elections in Ukraine was to show that in
Belarus and Ukraine in the aftermath of
Azerbaijan that the era of the
is over and now the process of stability
is or counter revolution is beginning
and this election week before the
election ukraine be a signal to certain
forces in Ukraine that the time has come
for revenge the last voyage voyage as
good as my shadow steed an abortive
playing abuse too much makoto-san
peek-a-boo with grey t mobile cranes
cannelloni but recently qivana policy
hardcore Moses is a turn a blue sea yeah
that was no demo politician opposes a
year slug lemurs latest beef Purdue's
know Russia home the Mogul IT industry
advising a surge in then being in minsk
in my experience of the belarusian
pregnant cultural association which was
created body you come to people's party
i can say that there is a not only a
Democratic opposition Bill Russell
movement and this is so and this
movement could be working much more
strongly than it is today Bell shailaja
pajamas he dosent matter semester when
you don't get y axis officinalis napisze
to do Gnostic rainy sure Sarah's nada it
was to us a la silla de todas Canal+
Bruce's study Mooney you'd he dope Amazo
visual ask you to see Ukraine you know
glass emotions te money plus a over it
just to see she contacted the Sugar
Creek mo is nasty sure let me go in
jeans unity of opposites in 30 below
bojangles body Judy Moody speed demon in
human emotion as I hope you would say
first of all judging from the experience
that I had from our struggle the early
90s and basing on where I saw I the
representatives of the pro-democracy
movement in Belarus are very brave and
with help
and with help from the fishing rod group
and from ukraine in asked their bravery
they constantly speak about this and if
you take for example all between the
encode being a college you can't help
but be impressed by his courage castillo
manana two variables in our two solid
honest wife Lucy just a proposition or
whiskey she just said wanna do screen
alone is public keeps the new agey entry
activist you who canal catechin on
logan-san facto sure Belarusian acid why
the way I certainly he stood firm you
type briefly problemas prostate you'll
de Los Cocos t- means who I Quincy Jack
las cosas se alimenta horny pasil he
came a proven a stupid operation
preserve any the new Scott Busse
masseuse pistol Shumate I'm a time honey
he remained until my English as
lukashenko his remain the question where
this question is related he is really
ovation Lukashenko the show solidarity
has very important influence on the
regular citizens below those taking part
in collaborations of Chernobyl and the
commemorations of the bureau's People's
Republic it was a very obvious that
the Russians were very pleased that
people have not forgotten about them and
the citizens the simple citizens are
very thankful about this and probably
one of the best things we can do is to
show his solidarity to build us that we
haven't forgotten about them and that
we're not in an effort don't equate the
isolation of the shampoo the isolation
of the people of below the belt
proclamation were political
consciousness into Nashville breno de
reus consent shimoga Zaza Pachulia of
last night net reward we're pretty sure
but he new phone case new glasses and I
beach in 15 ish I guess just a
presentational skillets and bureaus and
getting away from politics that I'd like
to state that probably the most
effective way of working with our Bureau
Russian with the bureau's is not through
that erratic political means but through
an indirect way through the cultural
Seth yellow motion said was no para esta
na yes Michael Anastas la san blas
issues in temecula Lucy Mae nikola
novakovic in val vista boo boo loo loo
skin missy lou dorchen accuse the same
as two people the tequila laquinta les
grands crus pisa eva larue squiddy
austriaca jawbreaker brick will be a
person to do that effectively yeah shoes
vs caprese panini mustache computer no
Horace Gorman say focus on school
effectiveness II Nicosia to bata Nanami
Kentucky I believe that this experience
is being transferred not on the loose
but also to other neighbors but give you
an example when we have an exhibition of
Bill Russian artists in Ukraine we have
a very large response from you pregnant
population below Russian diaspora which
is very large in Ukraine and through
this method we found it it's very
effective to use the art cultural way to
get new contacts which we didn't have
before shoe polish yeah navarre plana
post modesto cluster solution petite
movie key because they do the body
beauty today blue ce9 tell Sydney resume
Lukashenko the delay effective really
sold via militias and mascara analysis
p.m. / 2 centimeters analysis Rialto
cavanna normative WCC chanakya niti que
la mia visually christiana total you ta
Keo zavaroni know Reza what is Rio Bravo
novel oops sorry Steve the parish knew
Lucy contact we see Chester varnishes a
modern Alena Mae stood motegi they adore
me Allah be at work in effective name we
do skin factor Oscar places
gravitational tunica sorry Belarusian
and second of all we were able to see
that the whole culture of atheism that
existed in Soviet Union that that is
also a factor here Builders has a many
believers and these believers aren't
being allowed to pray in their own
languages did not being allowed by Luke
shadow government we found out that
there's a horse settles Orthodox Church
in bill Russa that there are other
person communities and they're not being
allowed to pursue their freedom of
conscience and contacting these groups
also helped us establish contact with
the Democratic regional chanya last
nerve borrowed a keen amateur players
were so a plumber Kenya chances naive
porshi Ukrainian same or diploma Hodgins
water simple need a mobile version not
aleni college of europe who Breanna a
key fact is no Simon said notch on young
a witness can't a good Europe SQ
hidan crystal dental sheds belarus e is
the shelters to that nasty darkest green
today as a Picasso is your moment will
discover Syrian official tribution
automatic the magic show that's what not
a more traditional villages nodoka
stitute solution Barney pretty natural
and also the third lesson is that
education is also a way to help
democratize bill goes through many
people from below us who aren't allowed
to realize their educational abilities
and there are many students studying in
the Baltic in Ukraine and being in a
comment at the college of europe i met
the three students for this is a college
where the future bureaucracy of the
European Union is being trained I met
three students from Belarus and it was
only one student from Ukraine these
students need help and this is also very
important way in the long run to help
democratize noodles yes not beautiful
Switzerland really talk a lot of immune
Scooby IDM okoboji y como glad I
kisaburo neolution
savita Belarus Gamorrean affectation of
opinion Premiership gurus Colorado from
two small deluded the lawsuit shetty
sensible any pollution practitioners in
college niki lauda to santa clara show
parody plan but you see to boot being a
man but is not from a year Yuma Travis
chaotic boo mod it with the ship
Ferguson was not the most depressing
being in Minsk and seeing the one and
only college there where the pillow
Russian language was not allowed to be
used for teaching you see how the deal
Russian students are are continuing
their application under the auspices of
the bill Russian national front and you
see how they're trying to pursue the
natural desire for education and this is
something that we have to continue to
support and again I'd like to stress
that this is a very good vehicle to help
our builders look amaze yourself for
modern water
musky Europe lens hace calor gas he
missed but kids and decisions cloudy
swollen and FML is electronic
differences when a bottle bit glossy be
Lucy and the informal approach the
approach using NGOs which is so much
hated by the father's you could say is a
very effective way on how people are
Kaiser bill oops yep how are you special
compressing from we're putting to select
repair equal to the politician in
plantsville risqueman Western patina
media charmila pinned by a Scottish
Maple hollow Brady to mushroom a bully
Yemeni proposition bhula dena yeah don't
you lose millet sesh this position
please no bara anasa NOAA data less many
coaches names kiddo each unit una dr.
lipinski Josie was ali yahoo that's a ki
baazi technique will turn on a shiny
redeem inches black peppercorns the time
i used to sutra wish it before the
practitioner lenses skip class
and getting to speak about the political
problems through through these methods
we were able to show and explain to
rebuild Russian so we're able to achieve
a victory by United and the pillow
Russians understood this in the United
around one candidate I hope they don't
take our other lessons that we decided I
hope they don't hate that lesson but we
see that using these methods of cultural
educational religious it's very easy to
to find ways start influencing the
political organization of the Opposition
in the belgic role of Christian is
another last minute class member plainy
should be loosened loser should we be on
the pianos like that kikyo speech
similar to start a problem is kicking
bootay especially pradosham in the oven
Pomerance LaRussa to last night
villarosas was made even emotion
particular solution manager i am going
to it read honest you may not only
Democratic Iranian gurus and to conclude
we understand that the pillow Russians
are very sensitive as to our experience
and they're looking to see how the
parliamentary election is going Ukraine
and you know they want to see that that
you are
we'll continue and not only the builders
opposition sees this but also the
moments of democracy are also very
sensitive homology promotion was because
he said bahistory ascaso jello bits a
Roman do the positive listen altucher
near 83 yahoo use most finish one radio
stars it was a persecuted wen Zhao Xia
seven-seater Tanya said the dude was we
was about a vertical estar cerca de la
soie London boroughs she's bikini as
balance forget the brain as SHINee we
thought she needed Balika Vadhu
schedules products and nary a delusion
Tom Cruise's said the torsion to mostly
to move a muscle supposedly purse closet
user and also no sign of cooperation and
also it was a bad thing of builders when
the EU refused to finance the radio
station we should be able to broadcast
rejected information into pillows but
the Moshe the poet has take this
responsibility upon itself and this is a
great factor and we're also planning to
do something similar in Ukraine in the
chilly hilly region where there is a
large pollution the Asura michele de
tois ethical tech specialist group it
would be
SI SE could make the case new glasses
baba ki you been to the flooding issue I
the mcd's Democritus a sudoku Moyes or
7p Lucy but she spit in his blood and
with it being you see as my personal
abuse Casper and also to bring up the
work that little al Rania's going
there's a a lot of work going on and
this triangle of Venus Warsaw on Kate
influencing abuse is very important I
know that in Venus they're going to be
working on a similar project is also
wash I'll be listen the Oscar there in
assam nasaan kinesiology star the
operative pro pro democratise tiny
skinny rupee self-sustained en el
headache in the Reggie Bullock big
mirror you to Santosh protocol gurus
over 11 years better you tomorrow yo
who's next royal lastly nemours already
pro-democratic soomaaliya ridiculous
people associate see chillin
in my uh Donatella nephrogenic
officially ask you peop dynasty signals
photoshop give Robin silly vini should
newborns also such Jernigan and in
conclusion we speak of democracy of
energy and this energy blackmail that's
going on in Europe especially what
tania's better talk about 2004 that the
bill Russians weren't able to to
withstand this this had a very big
influence and we in Europe we can't
allow these black regimes so to say I
continue to exist we better call
responsibility to keep a to have of
Europe that's whole and free now should
presume you lose your way to popular
particulars root of every Thank You
Loser meal plan to develop new solutions
even illegal in his nickname Decker and
our friends balloons say that wherever
the outcomes of the
next directions are the desire for
democracy will continue to exist until
expect thank you very much too shitty as
I listened to his comments I suddenly
recognized that the way the theme for
this meeting is being set up really
should be as broad as he is now making
it but theme is dividing ways to help
ailing neighbors become part of Europe a
Europe whole free my first read I was
wondering which was the ailing neighbors
it was tolling it whether it was Ukraine
but it's clear that the most dating
neighbor is goes it's a central issue
for security essential year and for
what's going to happen the western part
of the former Soviet Union and its
relationship with the European Union it
is an issue that I personally am much
involved with I served on the board of
the European humanities University at
the University that Lukashenko shut down
over the five day period two years ago
that's now being set up as a free
university in illness it is heavily
dependent on the support that will
receive from the EU from the outside
foundations
united states and from the lithuanian
government and it's clear that europe
including the european community and
commissioned the way vision operates
even bureaucracy within India and not
doing everything that they should and
could in order to pursue the agenda that
you lay out for promoting this kind of
activity that leads to a second quick
point for the last three or four years
now leadership within EU and within NATO
for addressing the builders question
with greater coherence and with a more
effective strategy and indeed with
engagement has come from Poland and from
Lithuania particularly from Poland the
triangular relationship the two mention
ukraine and poland away of which in many
ways traces back to the results
initiative but yes finished some years
ago seems to be utterly crucial because
even though europe is again wrestling
with this question chairman of the
Parliamentary Assembly of the Council of
Europe is again calling for review the
bill Russian question developing a new
strategy the UN Human Rights Commission
is a year ago going through the same
process most of these activities end up
being cyber bullying and from my point
of view utterly inadequate and groping
with an extraordinarily important
problem so I think the leadership on
this is going to have to come from the
three that you're talking about without
that there's going to be no further
forward thought Russian question which
is indeed very central no now we turn to
peck logo I think everybody will know
this is easily the executive director
for the Polish America Ukrainian
cooperation initiative Ukraine
initiative which is this critical agency
that operates across the border in order
to promote a whole series of activities
facilitating Ukraine's development both
in turn
with europe with the euro-atlantic
structures an organization interested
and has funded more than 180 for
projects that contributed to in addition
vention administrative local government
before international business standards
ethical standards in public life youth
empowerment all those areas earlier he
was the director of the bridges to the
east institute which as I understand it
was focused more we use careers as an
international international journalist
editor deputy editor of key publications
in Poland so I understand it he is
actually located in kia ora source x.x i
am located in here and these two series
is difficult to speak the last one this
is him okay and truth the old Chinese
saying let us leave interesting
interesting time and I believe that it's
happened to all of us
if somebody would tell us about 20 years
ago deaths Soviet Union will would
collapse and ohlen be a member of NATO
and it would be independent as i stunk
rain and develop Ukraine we would
probably laugh this night but it
happened and inhabiting such as with
such a speed that it's really difficult
to believe with his 20 years perspective
so you know has changed totally not just
Europe the cholera I'm very very
impressed with a with the presentation
of my colleague who said about Ukrainian
involvements helping no person
supporting democracy balance and I read
over whether issue of our research we
should remember the balance is a
neighboring
my country to power the issue of balance
is of crucial importance for you now
after his 20 years we have really
extremely challenging situation and most
of the most important events of all the
hindquarters is taking place in our part
of the regional i will be using the word
region i will not be using the words he
said at four or caspian to volunteer or
black sea i would like to use this
definition which is not an ignition just
a simple region region and regional
interests of all these countries and i
was very much pleased with listening to
mr. vishinsky see remarks about about
the historical and cuts all ties from
the past now we can see that after the
collapse of the soviet empire we face
the challenge of coming back simply to
the roots seeing things from different
perspective and learning about our
future power past and apply this last
experience
to our future achievements of course
it's not easy and as the Polish
Ukrainian relationship was not easy but
with the orange revolution there is a
new spirit I can agree that now facing
the two crucial elections in two crucial
countries pro crucial to the vision
country so its balance in the first
place and then then you cry and maybe it
will be a step back maybe maybe it will
be more difficult for 440 people to
believe to trusted democracy is a good
thing and NATO's in who think and it
would be good for you trying to join
NATO and European Union but it happened
also lift Owens so it's not a rose
garden is really a difficult important
task to fulfill I there is an action
plan drafted and instead of speaking
about the prospects of the EU membership
asteroids just follow this action
planets and pretty convinced that if you
crying will was a sit-in fulfilling the
requirements of the action bar the way
to Europe to the European Union will be
definite lumber and the next step is to
involve also you cry in helping other
countries individual like it's the case
of Ukrainian Russia
cooperation now we had some problems in
college my previous institution to to
bring the pollen some roots of Russian
youth for a study group and to helping
to understand how democracy works what
are the democratic institutions and how
how life on Muslim we succeeded but now
it's very difficult for us to to invite
these groups for balance because
Lukashenko made some steps in order to
control this process so they need to get
you some very strict procedures here on
country in order to get to get a
passport in order to to get out of the
country to power and follow us was here
to be the enemy of balance a government
and president Lukashenko some of my very
good colleagues journalists were
expelled for columns some of my close
friends one euro deputy were expelled
from Adams how I myself say persona non
grata that I was because of my
affiliation with with rivers but there
is a way to help the labs not in direct
way through the Polish Belarusian border
but we apply because the Russian people
need a visa to come to you right so
probably mr. Kishan Kaul discoveries
sooner or later effect a nice Ukrainian
ground good surface earth a grant for
sharing the Polish you may experience
with other direction friends which would
like who would like to change the system
so we are thinking about 30 bucks some
some problems police Ukrainian the
Russian programs to support democracy in
dollars and I'm really very grateful for
for all your comments and you're
interesting in others we we should also
think about involving you cry in solving
the problem of Transnistria and mono
it's also a problem of regional security
and as I go so far undp imagination
development project just launched the
huge project of monitoring the border
between Ukraine and Moldova this border
was really a pain in the ash of European
Union because of human trafficking
father in all these past things and this
project is successful it is financed by
the European Union
that's really a lot of changes happening
in the reading and I decided we should
say thank you very much President Putin
for forcing us to join diversity and to
think in regional terms we are not
thinking about our police interest our
new guy on interest our chat interest we
must think about our regional interest
about the interest of our energy
security and also about the interest of
the robbers a witness also thanks to mr.
Putin will succeed to the very big
extent and from this end of Europe will
be shaping the future of European Union
as well now the reset growing the month
for information on what's going on in
Ukraine in Germany ouch is involved in
organizing some some conferences in
Germany before the elections in Ukraine
we were approached also from the French
sites they are rumors about reviving the
paper trail so it looks that this region
still stressing this region will be a
region of crucial importance for shaping
the future of Europe and
I think it's basically if you saw what i
wanted to cover as ex DSP subproblems i
must say with this energy of democracy
because i believe this we have and
there's you without democracy as we can
skip democracy without energy thank you
very very much you know thank you very
much would be the comment because time
is short enough returned first of all to
change thank you young veteran one
chinese expression there's of course
another may all your dreams come true
and of course it's a curse so i have a
narrow question for mr. are cushy in the
broader question both the narrower one
is whether you to see that in his weaker
state president Yushchenko as we've some
understandings with Kristen Fuji about
not taking certain actions of support in
the owner rules Moldova elsewhere to
influence to influence one saturday in
the broader question is whether you
shall I on suspicion that a president
Putin's eyes the art revolution has been
and if so would you be willing to
reflect on the implications of dealing
they much more confident Russia
confidence she said the hospital i
purchase a competent
you is here we go a lot of us remember
those villa Russia free flex on the
Iranian of the streets during evolution
and efficient the math a memory is not
very strong but we remember what was in
our country little bits year ago and it
was very easy to speak with Belarusian
activist logicians and so on and it
depends not on the issue as a lot of
people father's moment in the rain who
could stand cooperate mr. Russia I'm
sure as the president we brain
understand
it as well but he is a president but and
are allowed to be interested but
Ukrainian society is ready to help our
friends into the Russian we may be
another we understand the helping build
are rushing to Margaret Democratic that
I Russia we help ourselves it's a young
do if I were if I did you are America's
leadership no I just wanted to uh city
mr. nibbles or a solution in sight I
know it's difficult for mr. booking to
judge because he's not traveling as Hans
it easier
person from the crowd but if you come to
Kiev now so you see the original she
being fair because people are smiling
the custom officers the other guards
they are those route they are trying to
be friendly people behave in different
way and you can't change it there is no
way out maybe as I said it will be a
step back it will be a problem for in
Turkish people are frustrated because of
some pressure flow from Russia high
prices whatever is the way I just wanted
it yeah it's funny cuz ur Ukrainians
have used to be very good with little
colder each Nicki that was a sort of the
yearly celebration of things and so on
in the old days at least even when they
were sort of indie I'm liberated stage
even Soviets taught them to do this you
know have shown my eye and Sons away so
I'm wondering the 20th anniversary of
terrible tragedies that affected both
Ukraine and and and Belarus even more
and certainly i'm polling of say this
youth by doing something that everybody
was sort of initially thought was crazy
you know feeding i doctored it for
because if this thing happens they
called Chernobyl now i was involved a
bit in the late 80s with the movements
of that were
there was an enormous ecological
movement that happened at that time I'm
wondering on the twentieth of an
anniversary especially if you have a
more democratic which is finally maybe
in weakened state or not we can save it
I quit the yutian cuisine at this point
we can you shake your governments which
means a very rough for me the road
hahaha what I said I was going to hit
could be using the government at some
point or or the folks have seen that on
another way because you were really
eloquent about that remember about you
know the educational and all the other
things but something like ecology where
one-third of the population of the rust
is affecting couldn't that mobilize
forces that were mobilizing the crane in
fact in it ladies because I saw them I
mean it isn't yep can that be another
hour opticare-ointment getting to wonder
there are a lot of these things that can
go on I already mentioned about support
genova see chef ranada throat the
largest amount onto the passion the
people
minsky's Turin gives us during the
anniversary of genomic I am seen remains
and resilience I think you are right
they robbed emotional and come on for
your grain of the Russians also
anniversary that investigate will be it
will be a lot of people to sweet means
anonymous every unless heaven back to
the quest of the G last year ago maybe I
can have both of you out on there's the
question of Putin and his entourage
calculations going into the March March
elections my impression was that coming
out of november december two thousand
four rather than drawing straight
forward lesson booties direct
intervention had been counterproductive
and therefore it was fundamentally
mistake with Russians to try to
influence developments in Ukraine that's
not the less than they learn I think
that food and leading to mislead
partially badly advised by his political
consultant
all skis and we can all Marcos and also
that he had been in a way trapped by
tissue itself in which this was all done
but rather than the political
consultants and then food and drug
lesson that it was an error and they
don't want to key it the conclusion they
drew who I believe is that they want to
do it again that they want to do it
right and rather than try to manipulate
political groups from the east they want
to have a broader defect within Ukraine
including civil society to begin setting
up things in order to do that on the
question of whether they feel the
momentum of events since there till now
has begun moving against New York
resolution I think that is generally
perceived that the house was their
chance at this point if it's especially
true Long extremists I was at a meeting
in Helsinki as a tulip did you can
imagine where he was but he was I think
about a genuine conviction for the
satisfied things of really soured for
the revolution the point of view on it
would substantially turn around tomorrow
but this is leading to a question to
both of you what is your sense of the
way in which the Russians have played
their hand this time in the lead-up to
the parliamentary election what are they
doing
he plays different cards now using gas
and this case was with us was like
shooting he's all right he elevated the
west and now there is a spirit of
consolidation in the West regard to
think about the original energy security
drop in energy security I saw I saw the
posters in here two weeks ago despite
was Foster's me attack attack initiative
so against his fish tank attack its data
and they had three slaughters first
Logan is no NATO the cellular slogans in
Europe yes athletes belarus and
kazakhstan and his third slogan is risky
as he died
yes hey of course probably to visit
Asheville curly behind these versions
and his movements possible the political
scene in Ukraine is dividing is very
divided it will be even probably the
party opinions win the election but it
would be impossible for them to move the
country they're on their house we will
see which one instance I can determine
sad lack of strategy and a booty strike
this parabola also 225 now the ways to
two terms because of strong Turkish
present in the regional and they like to
get thurs on their side so we would like
to involve there are some huge
conference in Odessa in here on possible
issues as the terrace understood
present touching also sent a messenger
to for his president yes just was
important so giving some signals this
cannon is ready for me for the year for
the serious tossed on the user
corporation yes but it's like testing
the waters no I can see the recycle
structure maybe we use it is it maybe
another day we never to speak about the
problem of Ukrainian to democracy I
think it was the help of Russia when
orange team have been divided ambition
Russian help I recent put in place
better this time maybe this is the
so-called economic mechanism and I think
they now they know what put the rain
politician forces represent they know
they're weak weak points at hours and
now they have no strong
brayan democratic 40 forces has spent a
lot of time for celebrating porridge
revolution not to fulfill their promises
and but I hope in wisdom of my my my
nation and as a result during the
parliamentary election will be the same
democracy will be divided department
well I'll be rich time we want to leave
enough moments for my colleague people
are true to wine things up so join me in
thanking
Oh
you excellency a mother come together
yes in ski Cindy students and here
college I released almost bikini
opportunity to make some closing remarks
I've been warded off I want it why I was
privileged in this way and I concluded
the problem because of my analogy I hear
both the gas and the post and of us
comes common con is on public so
probably I could speak on behalf of each
group and I don't use this opportunity
to express the gratitude to family
regularly to their speakers who
sacrifice their time and probably some
urgent tasks issues to come here share
with us their knowledge visions their
hopes and fears we should thank also our
boss Merle Harmon Institute which became
safe haven for not only to this
conference or for any other friend
Elaine
and for a grain program which is going
on here last year and of course we have
to thank the sponsors who are listed on
the website of our program there is as
impressively so there and this is a good
size that cranium issue Brendan academic
issues and Ukraine as a country are very
good enterprise it would be Robin Hood
investment so it's a gain electrons sign
all of us probably has great
expectations after the Orange Revolution
this expectations had have not
enthusiasts yes it was there is a
restaurant a patient to complain to
blame leaders of our solution who proves
to be a not of sufficient caliber
intellectual personal critical to meet
the challenges after the Revolution and
to use the trends window of opportunity
hopefully also can blame the society
again it is to be not so silly not so
diligent so goal-oriented purposeful
soul responsible as it happened to be
fresh acadia to an evolution also mid
lane international community didn't came
didn't kill the give support Ukraine
after who she didn't encourage training
information didn't give that signal
which was which was discussed here area
is the morning and probably I have to
explain what the signal means
miraculously a lot of resolve confusion
around this issue it's in the Westerners
cannot understand why Ukrainians means
this symbolic of signal and you guys
cannot explain problem why means a
trainee so let me let me put this in the
following way Ukraine an identity
historically involved as alternative to
Russia you could in order to list and
you can see and also they had eyes
either to have assimilated all the
disease so in order to disease model is
beast and this pressure from the
Imperial center they have to identify
self some other centres which should be
more sample sentence was symbolically
was measured ascended and Posey will
find this Center all means away are
interested now they
they are betrayed by this very standard
10 sack all Ukrainians cranes field is
that unlost treated as any other
European nations they are not treated
like like Bosnia like turkey leg
romania's a decisive answer in terms of
political maturity of economical
connectivist they're not much different
from any now from albania or any other
kind soul ukraine's still have feelings
as they are treated not as a high
schooler nation they are treated as a
sort of time I'm using a machine they
are not decoupled from Russia and
because of this this also denies all the
statements made by the folks life for
Falcon and such acts they sound
insulting they undermine the train and
this is my problem and they do not
promote the creation of this identity
because still Ukraine is in the process
of forming national identity the signal
processor was not needed for Central
News Center European countries probably
the single was needed for their wall
connections and for Ukraine and tacky
for the low connections it was needed in
order to make peace between them for
Ukrainians and prolly Turks this signal
is needed to make peace within
themselves between the text and between
the ingredients because both hands and
still are divided in regard of
acceptance or rejection of Western well
they still are these two countries are
countries where in the West still
established by some other spiritual
power in one case is Muslim policy in
other on the other side in casual
Ukraine is something like Russian new
imperialism is difficult to define you
know already so it's surprising that the
best-dressed understand pretty well the
station in Turkey as it gives a second
because they understand what's going on
there intake and how it's important to
use this signal in Turkish but in still
fail to understand why it's important
for Ukraine well but probably it would
be better to look as you can postpone
our bless like as half full not half
empty so am I would do that the main
achievement of the on Russia was attend
to the dog attempt to the return to the
evolutionary path of a part of
development I would employ again my
favorite metaphor of connected vessels
by which I mean society and Kundalini
they not connected vessels and the level
in both vessels level of water little
culture silk culture social capital is
more necessary as long as they read they
are elected by three elections they
rented by
independent media they are connected by
independent judiciary and so on in
throughout the 1990s disconnection
existed in it wasn't imperfect but there
was connection at the end of the 1990s
this connection was destroyed it was
lauded President Bush choice remember
decided to run for the second term even
so he had no public support he had no
popularity so important in this election
said had to destroy these connections he
had to violate all possible rules of the
game and after that the level of society
remains the same or improving improved
gradually while the level of really
deteriorated badly you know if there is
a difference between the levels is
increasing pressure will again should be
reached and revolution order to bridge
this gap so after that the Ukrainians
again have reestablished that can
actually in these two vessels and
Ukraine again he'll the government they
deserve the garnish is erected in free
and democratic elections i hope the
primary elections will be also free and
fair so it is at events became again
responsible themselves for their own
fate intelligible sons morton fendle
forgive us publish and are
under provocative title grain Madeline
who by this money through he robbed a
man that Ukraine is too huge country to
neighbors and Soviet eyes and this
country cannot repress you and
incoherent sequent and vision policy it
was very sad truthful but we had
recognizes to that Ukraine and not was
influenced not only by this nice Western
influences like you know our Empire and
political relevance is also a huge and
unpleasant legacy of Byzantium of all
that our mastery of Eastern Orthodoxy
authorities so one till prom was rise
that Ukraine most doomed to muddle
through today I would repeat the same
formula I believe that you can still is
marking through but today I would dare
to pay able to put emphasis not on the
world Martin back of the world through
so i feel that Ukraine is going in
basically the right direction I weight
slowly too slowly to incoherently but
but it's moving
and I hope you shoot people our efforts
outlet support our commitment thank you
very much indeed for that I need to say
goodbye to everybody but thank you all
for coming this is not the first
conference we've had like this this is
not the last conference we're going to
have like this but I will tell you that
each conference gets better and the
reason that you'd get better is not
because of the pessimism of Ukrainians
look at the glasses being empty but
because of people who are outside of
Ukraine and look at the glass and say
it's not empty it's not even it's more
than half full and things are getting
better and you can complain because you
know better than anybody what your
problems do they are but guess what
you're overcoming them and if you really
want to talk to somebody who knows about
that talk about the public face of
Hungarian diplomacy in the early 90s who
experienced all this stuff and have the
same frustration that you knew and
LeBron where it is today so there is
more than hope it is happening and it's
happening not in your grandchildren's
lifetime it's happening in your lifetime
so the next time you come to columbia
which i hope will be sold when we do
another ukrainian conference we will
move a little bit further up the well
the broader development and hopefully
you will all come back again thank you
very much see you soon